there is a difference and you know I'm
starting to see that difference now
because I'm producing other artists and
i have a small label where i'm
developing a couple artists myself and
part of the challenge is to not make
them just clones of you not try to make
them sound just like you or exactly have
your creative imprint on everything that
they do but to allow them to be
themselves and fortunately I've worked
with people who have their own style and
and have their own special charisma that
they have that is not the same as mine
and because of that part of my
philosophy is just to allow them to
shine but still to be a good editor you
know help them when I feel like they're
lacking in an area help them make the
right decisions with their career and I
think I've been able to do that pretty
well so far but I will see releasing my
first artist named Estelle and in May
and I'm really happy with the album for
sure and now we're in the marketing
phase now so it'll be interesting to see
how how that comes together and if it
sticks like we want it to stick but one
thing I do know is we made a really
great album